Oh la La
[Música]
lo que ha cambiado es la percepción de
feminismo hace siete años en realidad era
considerado un tema casi cursi
y la defensa de los derechos de la mujer
como sujeto supero pero puesto que puesto
todos sus ingresos en sintonía con los tiempos
hila dijo hassan al assabaa tarifas
nara la taz l ebanista jaun les testas
dicho de la minería tamara al arabiya sí
jovenes en bidias pero dijo un
siempre debate en walhain entre la la
que lindo en el estadio en el pullman's en
su paseo le da mucho y
asesinatos y la espuma es mala
posicionado el martes que también ha cambiado
son las formas de movilización
colectivo que
internacionalizado a través de las redes
social, en particular y por ejemplo una
coreografía que se inventa en la química un
sido recogido en todo el mundo
contra las mujeres del mismo pegado
carteles contra la violencia contra
mujer es también un patrón que
ahora se encuentra en diferentes
ciudades alrededor del mundo
en mi opinión los temas importantes son
especialmente el reparto del poder económico
la política y también el hecho de que la
techo de cristal aún no ha sido
encofrados y sectores rotos
el respeto social coincide pero tiene
matizado jean chico laliberté majri en
adaptador de enfermedades del acné
kassir en manama para estar allí y artes acta
whatcar ordeño en las vegas para decir
tarea de la nasa relacionada con alemania
operadores de au mur cassilas en bélgica
planta en claudine wamena este
admitir en mi guitarra al choghour
cerca de colmar west ham chelsea a su
iniciadores el golpe pero da a los
periodistas para financiar bal trad
función fin de semana haydn ravel en cannes
un particular es y por sap djokovic que
llegar tarde en charléty les la saf en ahdath al
estanque en sanaa watts y el loira ha terminado
en las páginas de las moussavas
[Música]
richard ping un mundo y en casa y fuera
el proyecto enfoque franquista para la
a continuación nos centraremos en el
iniciativas que funcionan en términos de
lucha contra la discriminación contra
mujeres con foco en las voces
también en las nuevas generaciones
que toman la antorcha y luego nos vamos
de vez en cuando haz alguna
temas como los derechos
mujeres en el ejército o en el deporte
merrill al banna mi tobillo tiene la losa
tn prana de france 24 80 litros a sus
trabajo o incluso en la montaña en baraqueville
hizo el tacaño almotamar con brazos todo
los males al puré llevado a la ruina
estamos en eso cuando eso es najaf
irin the 10th y de mousteru en serio
como ella claramente le disparó
lauquet kg prueba loggia time
héroes de estos temas políticos de
base la columna morris el cuadrado y cuanto
y el mundo que apoyamos insiste
alain también su interés no es otro que
la excelente paz a sus puertas
razas como la esquizofrenia requiere
en preparación perreault me ​​respondió
importante proyecto foto homenaje